jean pierre pernaut voilà idc il est
extrêmement populaire est ce que pour
vous ça a été difficile
absolument pas j'ai maintenant ça jamais
été c'est quelqu'un à déjà qui ne se
prend pas pour une star
non mais et pas par le regard déjà les
regards des autos démarrage justement
oui ma jeunesse je vous avais eu genre
ouais là pour son pognon et ça revienne
que lui oui j'avais conclu d'accord on a
18 ans d'écart là et ils ont dit les
plus hype une que lui elle est là pour
son plein vraiment pour son pognon c'est
toujours ça qui revenait vous disiez
quoi aux gens je les emmerde et verrons
avec le lait dans le temps et temps l'a
prouvé ça fait 18 ans qu'on est ensemble
[Applaudissements]
alors non mais et c'est vrai que voilà
il ya eu des épreuves compliquée avec l'
empire qui est sorti d'une maladie
importante
vous avez été là vous l'avez soutenu
légende en ce moment là ils sont dix
heureusement qu'il a nathalie dont oui
oui même elle le dit malheureusement moi
j'étais déjà passé par la maladie est
normalement une maladie qui est
foudroyante je suis vraiment ils nous
avaient eu un un con c'est une de ses
missions de royan ton neveu n'est même
pas un mois mais voilà mais bon c'est
long pour tout expliquer et justement
j'en avais parlé tout de suite à
jean-pierre et le jour où ça lui est
arrivé déjà heureusement que je le suis
toujours de près parce que je force à
faire ses analyses déjà pour son coeur à
l'époque et heureusement parce que sinon
ils auraient pu faire un arrêt cardiaque
à trois jours si je l'avais pas pousser
à la roue cyr gardiola parce qu'il a
effet justin et l'auto cardiogramme et
son cardiologue 90 où tout va bien et il
fait bon pour faire plaisir à nathalie
on va faire un scanner et heureusement
parce que c'est au scanner et était
bouché à 98 % c'est-à-dire que d'accrocs
il n'avait plus retrouvé un pack d'eau
que le droit de chuter dans la ballon au
calme total et pastels
voilà ça c'est la première chose 1 et
après oui pour son cancer
on avait des doutes par rapport à la
prise de sang et
et là je dis bah maintenant il va faire
que tu fasses une biopsie et puis de
toute façon quoi qu'il arrive il va
falloir assumer la prostate se soigne
très bien
et de toute façon je serai auprès de toi
pour pour te pour te soutenir de toutes
façons et puis c'est là où j'ai été très
importante aussi ça a été pour la
communication avec tf1 parce que le jour
où il a quitté c'était un vendredi pour
dire bah c'est mon ouïe s'appelle son
château rouge jacques legros pardon
jacques cyr jacques legros qui qui sera
la ja qui le remplacera l'a dit on a
fait comme si on partait en vacances et
tout de suite le lundi donc il est
rentré à l'hôpital parce qu'il devait se
faire opérer et avec jean pierre et tf1
on avait préparé un texte de ce qu'il
fallait dire mais on voulait attendre
après l'opération
parce qu'on ne savait pas ce qui se
passait alors jean-pierre l'a dit on
n'en voit pas avant parce que si jamais
je meurs tu serais obligé de faire un
deuxième
mais c'est vrai que c'était une
opération très lourde parce que c'était
quatre heures d'opération en sachant
qu'ils avaient des problèmes de rein est
vrai le moqueur donc que l'anesthésiste
était assez dangereux déjà nos jours
avant pour que le cancer est donc dès
qu'il était en salle de réveil qu'il a
dit son premier mot le médecin l'a dit
c'est bon il est bien réveillé tout est
là j'avais commandé qui est ensuite
envoyé les textes comme quoi il avait
son cancer et je voulais absolument que
ça ne soit pas tabou et parce que c'est
un homme comme tout le monde et ça
arrive à n'importe qui mais ça a été un
l'emblème pour la prostate note nathalie
je vous ai senti extrêmement ému quand
vous avez vous avez été serré que vous
avez une maladie très importante
dès que jean pierre a eu sa maladie vous
êtes dit tout de suite c'est à moi de
prendre les choses en main parce que
sinon jean pierre il va pas faire les
trucs
oui parce que déjà un homme en général
ils ont peur d'affronter la maladie
je trouve et bien sûr est ce qu'ils sont
pas vraies ce qu'ils sont pas
invincibles aussi jean-pierre mais c'est
vrai quand on est un tel succès quand on
est voilà est-ce qu'un moment c'est pas
vous hésitez pas à vous aussi de prendre
les choses en main et de dire voilà je
vais te prendre par la main et je vais
faire faire les les
les les analyses à mais toujours moi
toujours parce que j'ai toujours aussi
je peux pas mal de rêves prémonitoires
aussi d'accord je sens énormément les
choses c'est ce qui m'a sauvé ma vie
déjà et jean-pierre aussi et oui valait
que je le prenne par la main il fallait
qu'ils sachent que je veux que je serai
toujours auprès de lui que de toute
façon c'est un axe de temps et qu'il
avait une chance inouïe c'est que tf1 a
dit de toute façon t'inquiète pas tu
reviens tu reviendras et en garde sa
place parce que c'est important pour
guérir aussi la voir des buts c'est vrai
mais préférerait que sur ce thème
important